there's something real funky happening
in the mortgage market right now and
it's worth paying attention to if we go
back to 2020 when the pandemic struck
all of a sudden there was mass chaos in
financial markets stocks were down gold
was down bitcoin was down everything was
in a free fall of course we then had the
central banks and the politicians they
stepped in with massive monetary and
fiscal policies to try to correct the
situation the central bank went ahead
and had two emergency rate cuts they
brought interest rates down to zero
percent and their goal was to flood the
market with cheap capital if cheap
capital is available of course people
are going to go and they're going to
borrow well that's exactly what happened
and we saw mortgage applications both to
go and purchase homes but also to
refinance their existing debt absolutely
explode but now as the federal reserve
has started to raise interest rates we
get the mortgage rates at a 10 plus year
high mortgage rates haven't been this
high since 2010 and so what the hell is
going on in the market well if we take a
look here at the composite index what we
can see is this orange line that's the
mortgage rate on a 30-year fixed
mortgage and that blue line that shows
the mixture of both purchase and
refinance mortgage demand it exploded in
2020 but it's been coming down steadily
as that mortgage rate continued to rise
over the last few weeks then if we go
ahead and we take a look though and
let's break out the difference between
purchasing a home versus refinancing
your current debt the refinance index
shows that there has been a massive
drop-off all we're seeing is less and
less interest for people to refinance
now this makes sense because ultimately
refinancing is purely driven by the
monetary policy what do i mean if i'm a
homeowner already all i ask myself is
there cheaper capital out there than the
current capital that i have if the
answer is yes i refinance my mortgage if
the answer is no the capital that i
could go and get is not cheaper than i
don't refinance and so the main driver
of refinancing decisions is just what's
the rate for the mortgage if it's lower
i do it if it's not i don't but here's
the interesting thing and this is
something that we should pay attention
to here is that there's a difference
between what's happening in the
refinance demand market versus the
purchase demand market what am i talking
about well there's a complete decoupling
this black line shows refinancing and
the blue line shows the purchasing of a
home what you can see here on the far
right is in 2021 and into 2022 there's
been a complete decoupling less and less
people are refinancing but plenty of
people are still going and taking
mortgages because they're trying to
actually buy
a new home now when we ask ourselves why
that may be happening there's all kinds
of changes in work trends there's
obviously a rise of remote work
millennials are starting families and
moving into the suburbs and of course
there's tons of people who just want a
better work-life balance and don't want
to live in a shoebox in san francisco or
new york and that drives a lot of
purchasing decisions it's not just
monetary policy so ultimately that
decoupling is the intersection of the
monetary policy trend and the work trend
and the life trend and the work and life
trend is winning out right now now
refinances are down almost 60 percent
over the last 12 months and the demand
for purchasing a home is remaining
steady we got to be careful so for the
next five to ten years the united states
is going to have to become incredibly
proficient about building homes because
if we don't we're going to end up in a
situation with a worse imbalance between
supply and demand the average home in
america is now
starting at 500 000
that is absurd we're gonna have to fix
this problem or quite literally the
average american's not gonna be able to
afford a place to live hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time